hey there and welcome to pro flows
number 44
i'm cameron and let's take a look at
what i'm going to show you here today
so right here i've got some footage and
let's say that
you are required to possibly change
maybe just this top line here okay so
you want to apply some effects you have
to
colorize it make it maybe green or blue
and it needs to have a little bit of
glow
how do you go about doing that in easy
in the most straightforward way
let me show you how you do that it's
really simple so we're going to start
with
just applying some hue and saturation
and we're going to
colorize this footage so there we go
we're going to
let's make it
i don't know maybe somewhere right here
and let's also just boost that
saturation way up so we can really see
it
okay and let's also apply a little bit
of a
glow effect so let's go down to stylize
glow and
let's just play around a little bit
let's just bump the radius way up there
something like that and then we're going
to take the intensity way down to maybe
like
0.3 so it's just a very um
nice subtle glow there so that's with
the glow and without
and now here comes the magic let's just
apply this effect these two effects
just to this area right here so how do
we do that we just draw a mask
that's all we have to do is we're going
to take that mask pen tool draw a mask
there we go and we're going to turn hit
f for feather and we're going to
feather this way up to something like
150 pixels
there we go and here comes the real
magic let's just scroll this down let's
open up effects
we'll go to the first one hue and
saturation and here
is where the magic happens we can see
there's a
little box here called compositing
options with a check mark okay and
there's nothing
inside of here except for effect opacity
but as soon as we hit plus
boom there's our mask and it's only
affecting what's inside of this mask
now we need to apply this to the glow as
well because you can see
the glow is still happening to the
entire image so that's without and width
so let's open up glow go down to
compositing options hit plus
and boom it's only applied to this area
inside of here now
so if i go and i turn effects off on
off on you can see it's only being
applied
to this area right in here and there we
go
we've applied hue and saturation and a
glow effect
only to this top area right here using
compositing options
and masking